a very prominent black guy by the name
of Killer Mike just went on Bill Maher's
show Bill Maher begged him to endorse
Joe Biden here's killer Mike's answer
what are your feelings on the election
coming up I mean Biden and Trump are you
just depressed about that as most people
as a choice my my feeling is pick your
policy not your person find
out this
is this is not the Dallas Cowboys versus
your favorite team this is this is the
policies that will affect our
generations for the next 20 30 40 years
to come so close your eyes listen to the
policies that are being push so that
means you're
for that means I'm I'm for black people
in happy black history you're not you're
not saying one candidate over the other
hey man my he ain't goingon to get me in
no trouble
tonight but you can't get yourself to
say vote for Biden over
Trump you you want me to listed now so
now now I'm just saying can he get
himself to apologize for the crime bill
can he get can he get himself to get his
head out of his ass and say black people
you you are black regardless I need you
to tell me what I need to do can he pick
a coalition of former people who are
affected by Drug law street gangs reism
and crime and say I need you as a board
to advise me how to fix federal prisons
if he can do that absolutely I can so my
challenge is out there all right Killer
Mike there's my there's my fellow Killer
Mike when when Killer Mike and I are
together we're we are Killer Mike kind
of like Attorneys General but of course
Killer Mike and I disagree on
substantively almost everything he just
said right
there he and I don't like Biden we agree
on that we're not endorsing Biden we're
not going to vote for Biden but the
reasons why not are totally the opposite
Killer Mike here brings up the Joe Biden
crime bill as far as I'm concerned
that's the one decent thing the man has
done in his entire political career it's
good to put criminals in prison
president Trump passed the first step
Act act which was something of a
jailbreak Bill and at the time I was
quite critical of that bill but the
people who supported that Bill said well
maybe it can pry off some democrat
voters and that will weaken them
politically and it's a small price to
pay politically I felt it still wasn't
worth it I didn't think the juice was
worth the squeeze
but maybe there's a chance that in a an
election of Trump versus Biden when the
Democrats haven't changed all the rules
and it's not widespread mail and voting
based on covid and after three years of
Biden completely destroying the economy
and opening up our borders and dropping
to the lowest approval rating of any
president modern history at this time in
an election year maybe there's a chance
that Trump actually is able to pry off
some of those traditionally Democrat
voters especially black guys uh Snoop
Dogg just came out he was asked to
criticize Trump Snoop Diggity do dog
apparently said that he has nothing but
love and respect for Donald Trump and I
think it's cuz Trump pardoned one of his
friends I don't know the exact details
of it but whatever the reason this is a
reminder of something about Donald Trump
that I think unsettles a lot of uh
political nerds and ideologues right now
go to TN usa.com NES are you struggling
with back taxes or unfiled returns this
year the IRS is escalating collections
by adding 20,000 new agents in these
challenging times your best defense is
to use tax Network USA along with hiring
thousands of new agents and field
officers the IRS has kicked off 2024 by
sending over 5 million pay up letters to
those who have unfiled tax returns or
balances owed these guys are not your
friends don't wave your rights and speak
with these agents on your own without
backup tax Network USA a trusted tax
relay firm has saved over1 billion doll
in back taxes for their clients they can
help you secure the best deal possible
whether you owe $10,000 or $10 million
they can help whether it's business or
personal taxes whether you have the
means to pay or you're on a fixed income
tax Network can help finally resolve
your tax burdens once and for all seize
control of your financial future now do
not let tax issues overpower you contact
tax Network USA for immediate relief and
expert guidance call 1 1800 245 6000 or
visit TN
usa.com canw turn to tax Network USA
find your path to financial peace of
mind that is TN usa.com
slns he assembles kind of a weird coal
namely Donald Trump shakes things up
namely Donald Trump speaks about issues
in some ways that traditional
conservatives really like like when he
talks about uh protecting American
industry and when he talks about
rebuilding the American family and when
he talks about Law and Order I think
conservatives like that a lot and he
talks about about issues in ways that
conservatives don't like like when he's
trying to let criminals out of prison
but regardless of what you think about
Trump he assembles an UNC conventional
political Coalition and politics is the
art of
inclusion politics is the art of the
possible to quote ovon bismar it is the
art of the second best politics exists
in real life to quote cocaine Mitch
McConnell the winners go make laws and
the losers go home this is why it drives
me crazy when
some
abstract writer in in the Beltway area
attacks an ordinary conservative who's
actually doing something in public life
because that that actual conservative in
public life isn't following the fiveo
manifesto that so and so wrote in
National Review or whatever well these
conservatives you know these these PE
they're compromising on their principles
says the random Beltway apparat Chi
who's writing in the the uh suburbs of
Virginia without ever putting putting
any any skin in the game without having
anything really on the line in real life
politics you've got to assemble enough
people to win elections you've got to
advance a policy agenda that will be
popular that will be implemented and
that will get you reelected and so I'm
none of this to to defend certain bills
and policy proposals from Trump or any
other conservative that that are um
improper or in appropriate but it is to
say all Republicans have to do is pry
away like four to 5% of the black vote
and the Democrats lose the Democrats
lose basically every election and is
that going to happen I've been burned
one too many times on thinking that this
is the moment that the Republicans
finally win over a huge portion of the
black vote but I don't know maybe maybe
we've never had an election like this
we've never had an election where an
American original Donald Trump is
running for a non-consecutive SE second
term against the historically least
popular president maybe in American
history at a time when there is a
political shift that's been rumbling for
at least a decade
now I'm just saying maybe I'm just
saying maybe it could happen there is
breaking news this is real tabloid stuff
gilain Maxwell the Paramore and business
partner of Jeffrey Epstein is apparently
going to write a tellall book about her
experience with Jeffrey and on the
island here is the talk TV exclusive
from gilain Maxwell in prison no he
didn't I don't believe he
did I believe that he was uh murdered
well shocked and I wondered how it it
happened so she goes it's not not a very
long clip actually she she's asked do
you think Jeffrey Epstein killed himself
she says no Epstein didn't kill himself
I think he was murdered I don't know how
it happened uh but I'm gonna tell my
story the rest of the the reason I
didn't play the rest of the clip is it's
her complaining about prison food you
know it's her complaining about the way
that she's been treated in prison it's
just it's nothing and it's a it's a sign
that you're not going to get anything
out of this book look if it comes out I
I guess I'll probably read it or I'll
skim it at
least you're not learning anything about
Epstein every time there's a drip
ah new information we're about to unseal
The Client List right before Christmas I
I made my predictions for 2024 I said
you not going to learn anything new
about Epstein really nothing
substantively new and then 24 hours
later breaking news we're going to
unseal the Epstein Client List thought
oh maybe I'm wrong no I'm not wrong you
know what it's going to be we're going
to find out the same stuff we already
knew oh Bill Clinton flew on the
airplane okay Alan dtz was was Epstein's
lawyer yeah we knew that Epstein was a
member of maral Lago
uhhuh sure what what new information are
we going to get nothing and you know why
because Alex aosta the US attorney who
prosecuted Jeffrey Epstein said that he
heard from higher ups that Jeffrey
Epstein belongs to intelligence and we
know that his elain Maxwell's uh father
was connected to Israeli intelligence
and British intelligence and maybe
Russian intelligence and we know that
Jeffrey Epstein apparently had some
relationship with American
intelligence and they're not going to
let us find out anything so we can keep
seeing the headlines oh big tell all
here we go yeah okay we will
learn the the truth about Jeffrey
Epstein only when the intelligence
agencies want us to know about it and I
would not hold my breath for that man
what a great clip that was now hold up
wait wait wait wait hold on ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael NS YouTube
channel we'll see you next time